beagle je suis dyslexique et dix
photographies je m'appelle ryan je suis
dysorthographie et 10 graphique je
m'appelle anne-cécile je suis dyslexique
et desert au graphique ces jeunes
joueront un point commun avec albert
einstein mozart bill gates ou encore
whissell schurch il
il souffre de troubles d'apprentissage
qui leur demandent plus de temps et de
concentration pour comprendre certaines
informations ces enfants peuvent être
tout à fait brillant mais en classe ils
sont souvent incompris car leur mode de
perception est différent je suis dispo
aqsiq
et c'est ce sont des troubles
psychologiques et de motricité et les
problèmes que ça me posant qu'on sait
que le temps que je note des leçons de
profiter à passer à autre chose
donc ça me gêne un peu cette maman est
bénévole et chaque lundi elle sera là
avec la psychologue pour recevoir tous
les enfants diagnostiqués dix pendant
une heure
ceux qui le souhaitent pourront au calme
venir partager leur expérience
on n'est pas sûr de la pédagogie mais on
va donner voilà des petits conseils
pratiques par exemple pour la gestion du
temps pour l'organisation de l'emploi du
temps pour les examens préparer les
examens etc
donc voilà on est vraiment l'importance
a alors montré voilà vous avez des
capacités vous avez des dons vous en
êtes vous êtes arrivé jusque là ça veut
bien dire que vous avez des ressources à
bien vous pouvez encore en fait en plus
malgré le fait que quelques fois vous
avez des doutes
vous manquez de confiance ces lycéens
ont eu la chance d'être diagnostiqués
plus tôt dans leur scolarité
pourtant leurs professeurs ne sont pas
tous informés or l'adaptation des
supports pédagogiques est indispensable
et très officiellement le temps laissé
aux examens devraient être un tiers
supérieur
nous avons eu le cas l'année dernière
donne élèves qui depuis très tôt il
était suivi
il arrivait un bac scientifique au sein
de notre établissement il a réussi son
bac avec mention bien et là maintenant
il fait des hautes études donc comme
quoi on peut aller jusqu'au bout
lorsqu'il avait détecté assez tôt à la
jeter les enfants diagnostiqués dit ce
sont une trentaine
mais on estime que 6 à 8% de la
population est concernée l'école encore
beaucoup à faire pour donner toutes
leurs chances aux enfants différents